foreign
[Music]
how did you come to do Lady Chatterley's
Lover what was what what Drew you to
this material
it was um full pandemic it was March
2020
and um uh and I read the script I mean I
knew the book and when I read the script
uh I felt that it was a very important
story to set to say for the lack of
connection that we were also locked in
and and so remote and there is the theme
of Nature and imprisonment were so
strong and that's the theme that I
explored already in in my first feature
film in the Mustang obviously it's a
very different setting but uh the themes
were so vibrant in this material that I
for those reason I I really wanted to
explore them again through the Journey
of Kuni
um so that it started there
you
um so you did you work with uh David
Maggie the screenwriter on developing
the script at all after you decided to
come on to direct did the script undergo
revisions yes yes definitely I what I um
I I love this script but it was a 500
pages book so obviously when you when
you you know uh adapt it uh there's some
elements that I thought was
you know more prominent or more
important for me more visceral and I I
just felt the need also to tell the
stories through her point of view
through Connie's point of view uh and to
be like much more under her skin much
more like sensorial
uh rather than being more omniscient so
that was kind of like my my take on it
when I read the scripts
it's interesting when you mentioned the
Mustang and that the theme of
imprisonment and how those play out
differently in the films
um I hadn't thought about that but I was
struck to me
this does feel there feels another
through line to your work in in both
films of
I don't know exactly know how to put
this but there's a a focus on sort of
intimacy and also on on bodies and
physicality right I mean whether it's
horses or people or horses and people I
mean you the way people are embodied and
experience themselves physically feels
Central to both films
absolutely and the silence is also
playing a very important part the the
invisible dialogues and what I always um
uh like the in palpable what's what's
you can't describe or you can feel
and obviously Mustang with a man and a
horse but this one is it's kind of like
two Creatures two human being
recognizing that they come from the same
nature that they made from the same mood
and they recognize that and no matter
where they come from their background
they have this this this this
chemistry uh this Soul this uh cosmic
energy even coming and that's I think
this is
what I'm it's the most moving to me it's
when two people meet and what's what
makes them connected I feel like the the
the same nature there's something about
them to recognize each other being being
um
similar
were there aspects of the novel that you
were sort of willing to let go of or I
mean there are a number of different
adaptations of the novel for film and
television and I'm curious what were you
looking to sort of lean in on certain
parts of the novel more than others
um or was that already kind of there in
the script you yes there's a there's a
like the the class obviously the social
pressure but it's um most for me
importantly the a woman who takes
ownership of her body and that's element
uh is is obviously always a timely and
even even more today I don't know uh but
it was something that I needed to to
express and to um the the and her
freedom is through her sensuality
through the accent the acceptance of her
body of her uh pleasure and uh and
female sexual pleasure is rarely
addressed and the edge Lawrence was
actually the first uh writer to address
it and that's that's why it was so
scandalous and the the the the book was
banned for obscenity because there was
two scandalous to talk about women
freedom and uh and for those reasons I
feel like it's a
it's been written 100 years ago but it's
still very relevant and uh and and and
there's something about what DH Lawrence
really wanted to express is like
sexualities and sensuality is part of
human needs and it's glorified in his
book and as being a beautiful and pure
and uh and not shameful and dirty and I
think this is a very important aspect of
our society as like we we've been like
the body of the of a woman is oftenly
subject of tensions because it's not
accepted as a pure
um
pure shape or pure you know
elements so it's so it's I I I just
really cherished this um this book for
this reason because the message is
really really strong and is uh always
uh important to
you know to um to re-explore I I
since seeing your film I haven't gone
back and looked at the I think I've seen
one or two of the earlier versions of
you know adaptations of this but what
you're talking about feels my memory of
those earlier versions what you're
talking about is much
clearer and more prominent in in this
version than any you know the past
adaptations I mean it feels the heart of
the film
um but I'd love to hear you talk about
how you cast this because now I can't
imagine any other actors playing these
parts
um when did you when did Emma and
Jacques come to the project and what was
that process like of seeing if they were
going to be right for it yes that's uh
because Emma um when when I first read
it obviously it was
the choice of Kanye was so needed to to
feel modern but also a very vibrant
there is I I I didn't want to trap the
story Into the 20s I needed I needed
this this trajectory to be very Timeless
and accessible and uh and and
I had seen the crown and I I thought
that Emma
playing Lady Daya now was uh incredible
she had this incredible energy and I was
discovering a character that I I thought
I knew because there were so many people
interpreting her but there was something
so different because she has this
quality of being here and now there's
she brings you in the present she brings
you into something immediate and that's
a a very strong quality and she's also
she has something also pretty like that
crossed the decades you can believe her
today you can believe her in the 20s
it's it's she's um she's a kind of a
chameleon and and when we talk together
she really wanted to she loved the scene
dancing naked under the rain she was
like this is an image of ecstatic
freedom I want to explore it I never I
never done something that crazy in my
life I really want to do it for the
family I was like you're welcome please
and let's do it together so I said we we
actually wanted to
to bring the same energy to bring the
same
um
yes ecstatic freedom I think that's
really what she said was spoton was
really yeah so that's uh we we we
started this journey together and then
Jack came on board and and luckily they
had an amazing chemistry but that's
something you cannot really predict so
you're hoping for because obviously if
this is the chemistry it's there's no
film so uh but did you do any did you
read them together did you spend time
like how did you discover that that the
chemistry was there
to first meeting together they
immediately got along so there's
something that happened and I was like
oh that's that's a good sign yeah and
and they were had exactly the same uh
sense of humor and they couldn't stop
laughing on the first meeting they was
like oh that's that's great there's a
sense of camera address so that's a it's
a great beginning
um and uh and this you know they really
trusted each other they really trusted
each other and that trust was so strong
and especially when they had to expose
themselves so much and uh and they were
so brave to to do what they did uh but
they did it because
they trust in each other so much and uh
and they wanted to share this experience
together and and they really really
always were you know are you okay how do
you feel I'm here for you it was very
very uh a real friendship
since you mentioned it I'd love for you
to talk more about the scene in the rain
it's an incredible scene and
um I just whatever you want to share
about like how did you film that how did
you capture how long did it take to do
that
um where in the production did that
happen like had they already done a lot
together like other sex scenes where
they developed a
you know closeness and comfort or was
that early on in the shoot it was early
on I like all those all those intimate
scenes
[Music]
scenes and this
this a lot of rehearsals we did two
weeks of rear sauce with an intimacy
coordinator uh with we and and so we we
approached it as dancing it was
choreography so that uh it was
completely desexualized in a way that we
we were doing it it was it felt like
kind of like a dance like a choreography
so that's if everyone was kind of
disinhibited and when we did it on the
second week we did all those things in
one week so that we it was behind and we
didn't have any issues just like in
and uh and they were at that point they
were so they had this closeness and this
trust that
obviously they were like thrill of you
know
um
going and then snake it onto the rain in
the big fields there was odd but we put
a lot of music We Made It playful and
joyful and uh and they just had fun and
it was it we always had like a
choreography or shape but then they
owned it so it's not also like a lot of
improvisation and it's because they get
they were they had like this
um already this intimacy and this um
camaraderie that you could it's so
authentic
but it's true that without those
rehearsals we would have never get it
was so crucial to have to spend so much
time together every day and uh and talk
about it and because those scenes really
mean something for her and for him it's
not just like
uh intimate moments it's really like it
it really pushed their their their
characters and their relationship into
something like more transcendental and
uh and um and and also through love and
romance I mean there's so many things
that happens that so we needed to to
approach it as kind of like a
storytelling each time like through body
language yeah so the the dancing part
and being like was very important for us
the the scene in the rain I just think
it's so incredible it had I found myself
like it has so many different colors
like it's there's parts that are very
funny and and Goofy and then it's also
you know very erotic and loving and you
know I don't know it's just I love that
scene it's it's really rich
um in the film
um and there's obviously a lot of sex
scenes and a lot of intimacy you you
mentioned the intimacy coordinator but
can you talk in a little more detail
about how you how one works is the
intimacy coordinator mainly working with
the actors or is it with it's with all
of you as a group with you and the DP
and the actors to kind of coordinate
like how this is going to happen
yes we she she was working uh with with
me was the actors with the the
cinematographer that were involved in
the rehearsal because it was really
important that we were all we knew how
to shoot those scenes and we wanted to
share ideas like you know if that's is
if it's okay if we can put a camera here
is that okay if we you know do this this
shape uh and and she was bringing like
some pillows so that we we started like
really like you know they were just
wearing like loose
close and she brought some pillows so
that we we could just mime and just
um rehearse like the the all the
choreography and and that was very there
was really we had a lot of fun we
couldn't stop laughing it was kind of
sometimes ridiculous but it was very
playful and always you know we're like
okay so we have to do that let's uh
let's um let's think about you know a
choreography at this moment and uh and
it was uh yeah it was we we had a lot of
fun it completely broke the ice because
obviously it sings it it really helped
my work because it's hard to to direct a
sex scene and you really feel like you'd
have a perv like behind your monitor
like trying you know so I was thanks God
she was there because she really helped
me to also understand what I needed and
the authenticity and she was sometimes
she was like do you need this and it was
like oh that would be great but I I
would never dare to ask it was like let
me let me see if they're okay they were
fine so so she was Kendall doing she was
going a good director for those scenes
and without her I would have everyone
would have been a bit you know much more
embarrassed and I would have maybe I
would have never dared to really ask it
to go deeper because I would have feel
like a voyeurist and horrible person so
it's
an intimacy coordinator is definitely
such a a brilliant idea uh to have
someone you know who is like a very for
us for this family was a key person yeah
yeah
um could you talk a bit about your onset
your your working relationship with a
cinematographer Benoit alone or what why
did you bring him onto the project what
what in his work spoke to you
um I had seen it his um The Firm that he
did about Vanguard
Eternal gates from Julian Schnabel I
really loved his choices of frame and
lenses and colors that I was very um old
and vibrant and and uh and and uh and I
also saw his work in with Johnny cut
lolis but I saw his lighting was
beautiful
but mainly the what he did in Eternal
Gates like
completely uh seduced me and I don't
know and I I had working with Ruben
Pence on my first feature film he wasn't
free so I immediately thought about
Benoit and uh and it was such a great
match yeah I mean it's it's gorgeously
shot I mean the film is so beautiful
like in I every element of it I mean the
the Wardrobe and costume as well is uh
insane like Emma's clothing throughout
is that really there's a lot of the
whole clues that you could find in some
stores today actually if I'm not
surprised I have some tips if any of you
he's interested
um it was part of like our will to not
feel like it caused a period film or a
costume movie we we felt that it was
interesting to blend some different
periods of like obviously to respect
like the shape of the 20s but maybe play
with the fabric and find like Fabrics
from today different patterns uh
different like the
thing that would always
you would always like be okay it's
timeless
it's Timeless it's it could happen at
any time and that's that was really
important also for the production design
it's like the same just like what's
defined a bit the world at the time but
never to to feel too heavy so that's we
we never um
oppressed by by you know and it's not a
documentary so it's not you know
sometimes there were like a lot of
you know an anachronism
but that's not you know I'm like
sometimes some people were like oh but
it's not you cannot have that in the you
know it's not documentary who cares we
you know let's be free it's a film
um so yeah
um I'd also love to hear you talk about
um forgive me I forget the actor's name
I feel terrible but her husband
um the relationship between lady
chatterley and her husband I thought was
really interesting as well Clifford
um
I mean as the film goes on he becomes
less and less sympathetic and and she's
you know Freer and away from him but
could you talk about what like in
casting that actor to play that part and
how you sort of establish that marriage
in the relationship yeah because it's I
feel like you walk this really
interesting line where initially I'm
kind of with him and them together I
mean he's obviously not he's I know he's
not going to stay in the picture but
there's something very human about him
and
but it changes you see the relationship
change dramatically over the course of
the story so how you go about casting
someone for that challenge
um
we
uh for this one I really wanted to to um
to discover someone and um and we also
saw a lot of um disabled actors uh
to find like the the an authentic
um
feeling about really being a a trapped
and uh and uh
and so in my first short film I had
worked with a young woman
um who was who had like brittle bones I
had a disability and uh there is some
there is a truce obviously for
for the role that was
very important to to keep and uh and we
met Matthew and Matthew had actually
knew really well the the book he was uh
he's an actor he's playing on stage
um and
yeah he shared there is something his
vulnerability there's something about
him because I didn't want this per
character to be just the asshole like
just the bright guy or being like just
the you know like the ignorant husband
he needed to we needed to have empathy
for him and uh and I think that's what
Matthew does really well not only just
because he has a disability because he
also understands
um the the
the need to to to to to to exist and to
sometimes being uh
try to control trying to compensate
something and uh and and I thought it
was you know very moving in in his
audition yeah no I I thought it was a
great performance in in just the way you
described it's it
I can imagine so many other actors just
going for the asshole which he
definitely brings I mean he's he is you
know
um but but he's human and yes I think
there's some there's there's a there's
definitely some a lot of humanity coming
out yeah um that feel more nuanced that
uh just being you know
um
and that's all yeah yeah yeah
um so I'd love to hear you talk about
the editing process on this I mean for
the whole film but especially since
you've already talked about in
production and and how you were covering
all the sex scenes like when you got
into editing how did you and your
editors work on building those scenes so
that they worked narratively and did
everything that brought all the colors
that you wanted them to have so I work
with my editor since
10 years we always worked together since
the the first short film I made so that
was that's a my closest collaborator and
I trust her blindly and so she started
to to to to cut the film she knew that I
really wanted to emphasize on her point
of view and uh and her story so
everything was kind of like you know
pushed toward this uh this this this
this feeling but also like the binary uh
uh world like the the inside and the
outside which was something that we
explored also in in the Mustang like
inside the prison outside of the prison
and that's also something that we
created together to really feel like the
entrapments the in and outs and uh and
um so she
she did the first cut and then we we
worked together to to to what was the
most challenging is to feel uh is to to
have really have the love story that
works to feel the passion to feel the
the desire the sensuality and to make
sure that all the senses was were open
all the time so she was um
she worked really hard to kind of
capture and it was a lot of work like go
and especially the the the sex scenes it
was really hard to to edit for her uh to
make it believable and sometimes you
know we felt too much so we had to took
out and we we needed to find the right
balance between sexuality romance love
playfulness
um all of the ingredients were very you
know delicate to to uh to to measure
the whole central part of the film where
you kind of track their relationship as
it starts and develops and and grows
over time I it's really I mean it's
obviously great performance and great
directing but the editing is remarkable
because it's just you know you talk
about a dance it's like it's this
modulated build of showing how that
relationship grows over time I thought
it was beautifully done yeah thank you
yeah
um it was also like the camera like the
camera work very loose
um untraditional for like this you know
kind of film there's something about
always in movement and for me Kuni was
always in movement she's Restless
so I think that's uh it was like the the
editing an instrument where if we bring
um bring this motion
I we should also talk about the the
composer and the music for the film um
can you talk about it's Isabella Summers
yes
um we met uh we met in London she's um
she's a foundator of Florence and the
Machine uh she was uh she's now a
composer for film and television and in
uh and I I had listened to to her work
and there is something very uh what I
loved it's how she plays with the
instrument like classic and modern and
mix and and her something really uh
unexpected choices for instrument that
brings like some
um um tones that uh that that you know
flirts between classicism and and
modernity and that's what we really
um enjoy together is like how to
modernize let's not go for like a
traditional classic score but with
classic elements so there's a lot of
piano there's cello but sometimes you
have like unexpectedly you have like a
bass electric bass or you have like some
drums and and and and and we we wanted
to do a score that talks about the story
but also to find the right instrument to
talk about Kuni and to to Really track
her emotional Journey and um and and so
we yeah we went through like some
um
areas that that uh that felt something
completely a little bit so you know
maybe too modern but we really enjoyed
it and and uh and it came organically uh
but uh yeah she's extremely talented you
know it's a joy to work with her that's
great
um well lastly I want to ask you about
um
you mentioned that the film started it
was early covid so the whole development
everything was during the pandemic
but now the film is coming out in
theaters with audiences and you've been
was it tell your idea your first
Festival yes so you've you've I'm we'd
love to hear you talk about your
experience of seeing the film with an
audience and and seeing it come out in
the world sort of the the first time we
saw it with an audience it was at
Telluride and uh and we I was very
surprised how people left I had no
predicted at all that this film could be
funny at any in any degree so to to to
hear people reacting and laughing I was
like wow this is that that's that there
was a big surprise for me so there's a
it was a great and nice surprise
um uh there is someone that was in tears
which I was extremely moved and and uh
and happy for him it was really like in
tears but I was like thank you thank you
for your tears yeah
um
so no it was uh it's always like it's
like giving birth it's like how how it's
going to be how it's going to be
received and it's it's like it's real
and finally it was it was a good
experience so that's great yeah that's
great well Laura thank you so much for
being here tonight thank you thank you
all for coming
[Applause]
[Music]